southern Germany is certainly not short
of woodland
and that's good news for the local
economy here in this rural region there
are many successful companies that are
leaders in their field see on your table
between Atlanta see you've seen the
wonderful landscape it's an area rich in
woodland so construction timber is in
plentiful supply here and we have the
specialist knowledge of our staff oh
these are great production conditions in
so far in via hygienic okey my products
even the claps company has a turnover of
more than 100 million euros a year
the next team baths and saunas should
desire eternal this one's headed for
Doha claps is not the only global market
leader in this region they're more than
80 others within just a few kilometers
and they can all buy hardware right next
door
successful companies attract suppliers
Illig is one company that benefits from
this arrangement provides for inference
if we were talking about synergies then
the crucial effect is that these
companies can draw on an amazingly
well-developed supply structure that's
the major synergy effect Goodman we can
get most of our important components
within a 100 kilometer radius of
Heilbronn I wouldn't I can just be
common
alig is also a global market leader in
its field
it makes machines that mold packaging
the best-known example coffee is
compressed into capsules with machines
like this this part of northern Bavaria
and baden-württemberg has many big
companies and westrom explains that it's
not a mere coincidence feeding on mdhil
I've met many companies that are world
leaders today were set up elsewhere but
after the Second World War they were
rebuilt in rural regions which weren't
so badly destroyed in the war that
happened in the 1950s and 60s before
fixing and so they grew and developed
tucked away here are falling apart
um buses so we knew physical safety on
Paseo Del it was an era when agriculture
was becoming unprofitable and many
farmers had to look for new jobs the
under some Island it's all fatigue in
food on the one hand they perceived it
as a move away from agriculture into the
factory on the other hand they were used
to working 24/7 farmers don't have
Saturdays and Sundays off
the companies didn't exploit that but
they were also happy to press ahead with
things to keep on working on things
until they were finished our by tip is
for these bar nowadays skilled workers
are in short supply here for example see
you are beg a global market leader in
the production of fans seeks to attract
employees by offering the ultimate in
job security it guarantees its trainees
a job for life from their very first day
you listen Wednesday you may have to
find young people yeah give you affair
like raw diamonds we have to get them
the end of the company train them and
keep them here develop there's a lot of
competition here for the best minds that
doesn't just mean people who have a
university education but people who work
in production who make the products
products und product a podium it's
Andrea's Shawn's job now to attract
skilled workers from all across Europe
to come to work here in this region of
top class companies